Now talking to mr.
Tom ivory who worked as
a an apprentice boilermaker in the dorman
long workshops during the building of the
bridge. During member those times you
remember getting the job day of mr.
Ivory. Oh yes yes i remember them. I
mean you see that signature on my my
you know like papers your reference yeah
yeah i was quite nervous you know mind
going well only sixteen. And we had to
sign papers you know we're going to
witness the leavening like that and you
can see the sea the sealed the sealed and
everything has signed mr.
Henry martin is there a mr.
Alfred martin martin and when you started
in the workshops what job did you do
first. Well i work with pain but fine
and course the marking off shop.
And i minored all the pamphlets and
everything we had special templates and we
marked the angles and food. But. Our
talking to me to pine over there at the
point. And he said to me. We've got
a good pattern aback because our mark you
know food because there was no meaning of
anything necessary. When
they were drilled and here's
a marking office first class everybody
recommends it. Do you do you remember going
up into the market into the template shop.
Oh yes yes that but we used to call the
loft. And. All the temple to
the different places to lay it out and then.
They made the templates. And of course
we use them only angle and so you know
markov and. Then they were of course
everything was doubly checked. I mean if
we had to mark anything. My boss checked
it many got someone else to check
it. All the time. So we could
act and how do you ensure that the tapes
for instance that you used for measuring
were exactly right. Oh my word. Yes they
were they were tested all the time types.
And i mean all the patterns and everything.
If they were marked they were doubly
tested because with the tribute of the
timber or anything like that we just check.
How did you go and for temperature if they
changed in length by the temperature.
Well didn't didn't matter so much in the
workshop because the. I think it was all
allowances for shrinkage and expansion
and you know all the time is
a big gap in between. The join is either
expansion joint charlie brown talked of
giving them
a drink in the harbor occasionally.
Well the only dig i got was when when i
joined when the bridge was joined.
We're going to twenty cents. Twenty or
canberra two shilling for beer
and a half a holiday with mr.
Freeman with them and that when you were
did your marking out after that the
cropping and the and also the drilling
was done. Do you remember exactly
how the shot was laid out.
Well it's all the same. Well
a moment and then we had another section
like it was all put together. And
the you know like the certain sections.
Then as it got heavy and went into
a heavy shop and it was all
machine fine. No ledges only
on a patron i think any here.
Get into play here. Will be
a little bit of an age and they had pines
big moving fine and i used to play only
proper so i can take
the edges of the world
was that different to other jobs you
worked on later. Well we moved around the
family line you know like we did a bit
of assembling. And i've still got
a little punch. When we used to make the
washers. Will they strip in
a piece of cast on when i punch you
know. And i think most you carry
a piece of shell. Went into the
tin you and when i move like that
they all the time. All they locate and then
later on when they should. Don't worry
about not moving. Carry that
for fifty years can make that
a bit clearer exactly how did that happen.
What exactly happened. Cast on when
a punch. Will not not like mild steel or
anything like that and it just shattered
a center punch you were using. Back then
a center punch you were using
punch inch inch punch making
a hole for washers. And this piece.
Pushed in you know i can we went numb
through lecturing it just bang it all
question pieces iraqi i didn't get any in the
head who put the face
a cast iron and no one written nobody.
The believer finally can't but
never on the culpable thing
happened was it done as
a joke or it was an accident was an
accident act and different thing. And this
machine used to punch out wash as punch was
she yeah because when the assembly when
doing the simile it had to be tightened up
you know and the watches were pushed on
. To make sure the tightness in
my riveted light and held in
position you know part do you remember
any other accidents in the workshop or.
My my good mate jamie never when i tried
heavy heavy party to go through my
head of i'll you know work with a will
a bogey you know and you to go into the
heavy shop. And of course when i moved and
that jimmy went underneath and he got
a leg he paid for asylum rugby league
one of the first representatives.
Terrible thing to get compensation
for that where i wouldn't have
a clue and when we could. It was just on
the finish of the. Fabrication shop you
know. Well i wouldn't have wouldn't know
anything about the compensation part you
know i would have got compensation and the
compensation started in 1026 where do
you see that happen now. I didn't see it
happen. Well i mean. We were all around
the shop and we heard just one of those
terrible thing. And of course i'm
a boy you know i think there was
a kind of in the heavy shop fill.
And you know. Well not on the
kind always accident was there more
accidents there than elsewhere. Oh no
no no i wouldn't fly. You know like they
had all the first day there wasn't any
terrible accident. You worked
there from twenty six to thirty
thirty one when the workshops closed.
That's right. And then from then on it was.
Depression for
a while. You know what happened to you
when you when you were laid off. Oh well i
work on my belly farrier
you know under the big two
as i was hearing horses and you
know anything for you know
could we ever on the dow now and
everyone of our neville now will i
get to them up you know like you keep
going and afterwards pull you know
news on the staff holding.
You know work. You know
that you're well about twenty
or thirty well that was that
. There's only room for
what you do in the lunch was there any
sort of fun and games used to go on in the
workshop on which to get down going
down to the wharf and mako would
do anything sharp and get the mackerel.
We could get ten for them. Do you mako.
And some of the english boys they didn't
know what they were made by animals. For
them and they must always get my fill.
Picking up on the angle with fire.
That was
a wide open fire. You know like and we put
the mussels on the top and bang beautiful
tasty. Bit of an indoor toilets.
Yes it was good. Anything
else you remember during the lunch era where
the place to go up in the well the big
boat used to come in with the thiele. And
we go up all of us to seamen and they
kill the sheep. Have a ceremony there
and then. When they have their meal
a real big party. Let's have the big like
a lebanese been you know that flat and
they just get it all into little time for
. Did you go up the arch at all. Oh yes
you know i had to go up there. The little
mite was only remarking we got
it up there and one of the
plates. I found it was loose rivets. So we
had to take them down and we had to get
it down. And we were over on the pylon on
the south pylon and the kind liven up the
top wouldn't. Lola play down by gently
down we said will operate over you
played well and willing to
take million. But we've got it
. Was there many loose rivets.
Oh no. We picked it up again and
i replaced the derivative alone job to
remember the inspectors marking rivets
because our inspectors found it. You know
like and that's what they made it bring
it down again. How did they cut the rivets
out in those days they didn't use oxy
today. Now the only option that was
used on me would be. There was
a maintenance chap he used to
pay you know i think not not
kind of bring in time
with anyone he used to do
all the odd jobs. And he could cover and
use anything to small welding jobs or
anything like that but that's all we do
remember how they cut the rivets out then.
Well i can't i'm out with a set a pneumatic
chisel and set. Oh yes i will i mean
a big fridge and but i made
a one time really came out recourse they
were tested in the shop and i have been
and i mean anything anything at
all to grantland they were very
particular specters very good men you
know like on the job. Do you remember
if any of the holes were drilled wrongly
what happened to the steel then. Oh i
would not know how long i mean because i
would check checked and double check and
see the batteries of drill. I mean if they
were always piloted first part of how
open they are you know. Yes
well i had heard about
a few plates that were wrongly drilled and
they recommended up in the middle of the
harbor or i could have
you don't admit stakes.
I think could happen you know but there
wasn't too many. Yes. So they wouldn't let
anything by regardless because all they
see the steel major the steel came from
middleboro and i mean it had to replace
that type of steel mill good height silicon
do you remember whether any of the steel
was already drilled when it arrived well i
know some of it must have been but do you
ever see any ready drill steel. I mean
that most of the base and the time of the
ship they weren't drill where the little
all build and all the marked building which
up the triangular buttress plates do
you remember them arriving from overseas
already drilled. Oh well i could not to my
knowledge anyway not my knowledge. Gemma
cutting and drilling them cutting and
drilling the small triangular
batteries play it well they had
a good machine if they
had copied and they had
a big. The. Do you remember how the large
plates were handled once they got into
the workshop or like time out directly.
There was
a big mangle and i mean that they were
straightened out and quick prediction
trolls would be no kinks through anything.
It was all through the big mangled and i
think
a matter of. twenty and thirty feet long.
You know movement could be up to an inch
and
a half. Head of one trample on the angle
iron twelve twelve one inch angle
loan. And i made
a little to each square of it and
that tunnel held that now. To do
just that about the only thing i had i had
a particular cable. And of course i don't
know where that went with them bring some
of my sisters. To took
a moment i was something to the paperwork
properly. Do you remember also the angle
crimping and the angle cutting machine.
Yes yes i mean it was all night caps and
everything like that and the angle from
time about fire land that they used to job
all the angles travel
more let's put a bit of
a syringe to put them into the other section
you know keep and level. And that's
the big gangle treat spyware we used to
the team at all from it. And at one time
. They used to light the fire and
then crimp the angle to what to offer
chocolate. It was just like
a little set more or less set you cool.
But had to heated because out of all the
the angles. You know you know
right. But could be said the
same as the machine with a straight
and angled a big angle with just like
a two to sort of believe
it's where they could widen
the space and this them used to come in
and just gets enough. You know like the
state may learn all that modern
machinery beautiful machine where
did you live at that time when you working
on the bridge. I lived at park street
control and then moved out to do
what they call you to call days evil
now taking for. Long but i need to
get the tray me and frame into the
way and get the whole fam down to the
key and then we used to get caught in
a very easy get weekly ticket. And that
was and then for you know it to work with
a good tech. You know like me
for really of the work we were
plus a tech time. Plus the time it takes
a country. Plus the time used to go to
tech as well as mine and that was just
in our own time the tech. Examination
if we pass an examination we got to six
rowers. And if you see the wages lift the
7-eleven went to first see who you were
up there before it was closed where you
and over the top. Oh yes yes kind
of course but we got we handed
you to take is only three quarters of an
hour to get up. Where do you mean you've
got wonder will we get into the
management. If we go up there anymore.
We'd be you know weapon but
you actually got up the creek
a crane and across the from one side to
the other kind. You know like they just
almost to get them. We've got up there and
we could pull up my top of the time and
come naming others. So you would actually
have got across the harbor before mr.
Ennis crossed that bridge sure
years will be by how much
a little anyway because they had to wait
for the right time for the june. I think
was about two o'clock in the morning will.
They finally lock and when was what was
it when you you youngsters
whenever i would never
you want to have the cooperation of the
crane driver didn't you. You know until you
see that lunch in the movie having
a lunch. And cause that villain
to top the top one kind
and how did you actually get across from
one crane to the other where you because
you are very close. You know like
almost your own. But wriggling reboot
and doing. So you break mr.
Ennis but actually when you when
you see the one you can drive
a car and over the top and i'm one
of the people they had a bit of
a pathway. Will they might stay away. You
know for the workmen. Veteran that chap
in the might and chap you know that was
all he was doing with my little steps and
so forth. Do you remember the carpenters
making wooden ones before the steel was
put up the steel steps now you know it
would be temper your mind. It wasn't true.
Yea. The final tape you
know the gentleman is also
a reverend and they used to build
a little log precedent rifle and. Do you
remember any amusing things that happened
while you were working there
amusing little english boy or not
a boy i little english assembler to
larrikin to give him every monday
morning they woke up showed
a pipe and i signed you going to put
some money in for something. In the pub
spin and it happened every monday
morning. Well i don't know
any other things you know. Let me
think. A linguist married when he
first came out he didn't know much
about the worries of our israeli
tobacco only wanted to back down and he
told about the cigarette. I misread it.
Pleasing to read it give him an
edge. And say anything.
So he called me one
day i was in my hands were
calling on behind me back. It's
a charming moment. Jeremy
burley will only trouble up.
Before knock off time people enough time
and i don't turn you about that big punch
me shown the start. It was
a little. Generator like and if
you pulled a bit quicker get
a spark. And
a big flash. Which get the other young
boys when they come and say stuff that up
my mind to get behind
when he thought it was
a rumor and given to shop and i being
the big flash of light. You know
i like them for their
law. As all these things
always go on in various jobs young
and we were only young for anything.
Is there anything that sticks in your mind
over all these years. Do you remember
for instance the day the arts was joined
you when we're getting. Yeah well today
when we got. The canberra two shillings
and we got to have a day of
to have a beer. That was mr.
Freeman where where were you
when the bridge was opened.
Down on the mine in remind of what you
know. Because the crowd you know crowd
only bridge. You know i think for me
what from the media will be down.
To the material around him were one of
the birds probably in the family work of
my you know i ring was there
in sydney or in the sydney
intrigued me really
chappy had
a particular time about five or six men
working for him lead to drill only big cult
big club and do
a bit of trouble when we can.
Well. Where was his workshop.
Eligible relatively neutral
. Maybe liberal without
a military blurb in them and made him
rich up
a little liberty bitch but i wound up in
my little big challenge and they told us
to be middle of the little by religion
illegal. Climate and everything like that.
You know my little premature. Liberal before
bill will be the really feel terrible
thing to remember that it was him he helped
you. You helped me before you went on
the premise that there be no global crime
each claiming to believe but the blimp.
Will be rebuilt lebanon and all it
will it. But my duties will lead.
But for the bits of evidence. It was you
and i might be able to be above the bridge
when that would be trouble
between publicly but
between bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla probably clipped
the public liberty club deliberately.
The problem will be able
to do it. And it may be mel gibson liberal
. But tibbs prepped probably but the public
probably will be able to predict what
it will be but. I think
a lot of it will be the main thing the
blow moment trying to work at press
time around. I remember it will it
mean for the gallery but the read to
a repertory.
Every relate with really rebel
women women about everyone most of
them when police put
a bullet. To
him every restaurant programs we
milled around some of them rebels
the rebels the rebels globally maybe
a little believed by rebels.
To recuperate with ms phelps like it
would. When people remember when the real
winner but what remained of politely
showed up there. Exactly who else was
working around their. O levels.
The elder the elder spent
a long time. Well it was only with
alec stewart. And then there was
a jimmy berman's woman and they really
appendages. But they were different. Alec
will work that it's all good but when. But
then on the threat level charlie blaming
only the inferior was
a panel of men. We wish to to
love and i think you have edge in
terribly lightly that i
work on the opposite. So
a lot like that between didn't actually
. Company. We're just separate clicks.
Yes well as
a matter of having accuracy with which he
remarks and we drillers drill this was
really remarkable. Or chilly here is our
mind but finally said to me. Should we
have to be congratulated. And we've got
we've got good marks on the wreck and none
of the hole had to be reamed or anything
they would get right on the spot.